my name is Jay Garrick and your world is
in danger when you created the
singularity above central city you
created a portal if he got through
they'll be more to follow
I always did like a man who could handle
a gun should see my nerve collection
you
hey youtubers is Charlie so it looks
like Barry Allen found that missing
thumb drive with the flash season 2
trailer on it it's not the full trailer
but still it's the next best thing so
there's gonna be a breakdown we get our
first full-blown look at Jay Garrick
that's really looks like the biggest
thing right off the bat and in his
speech he confirms that a lot of the
villains this season are gonna be coming
from Earth too when you close the portal
you created a wormhole he came through
more will follow and in the trailer we
see atom smasher so it looks like he's
talking about him when he says more will
follow
but Grant Gustin did say in an interview
earlier this year that we would see zoom
come in the first episode so he might
also come through the portal Jay Garrick
might be talking about zoom when he says
more will follow
usually trailers are a little bit
misleading the Walking Dead is the worst
offender when it comes to that they cut
a bunch of WTF scenes together that tell
a story that has nothing to do with what
the actual story of the episode is we
also see some awesome Cisco golden
glider action they'll probably be the
most exciting non-relationship
relationship all year long seriously I
feel like stuff like that is always
better when it goes unconsummated like
when they don't actually hook up and get
together and speaking of relationships
killer frost Caitlin snow and Ronnie
Raymond firestorm now they were both at
DragonCon
rot Robbie Mel was at DragonCon but
remember he's not gonna be around for
the entire season and he's not going on
legends of tomorrow that we know about
so his attendance at conventions has
nothing to do with what his storyline is
like actors that get killed off or
actors that go on break or hiatus they
go to conventions all the time I think
there was actually a picture of him or
one of the actors talking about working
with them on set pretty recently and
they haven't quite gotten around to
filming the mid-season finale yet
they're not quite that far along episode
aid is actually the Vandal Savage
episode so if shit's gonna go down is
probably gonna start in episode 8 and
carry over into episode 9 if you
remember the promo poster that they
mocked up it was a cover image of the
flash of two worlds they just did it
with Grant Gustin and the actor that's
playing Jay Garrick and the actress
that's playing patty spivot they
transpose them onto the original cover
in the flash of two old story that
picture takes place on earth two so that
makes me think that patty spivot is also
gonna come from Earth too but we don't
know that for sure for now it just seems
like most of the villains will be coming
through but for those of you asking
about Gorilla Grodd he's still earth one
like he was created on our
he's definitely coming back but because
of the special effects that usually
takes a little bit longer to do those
episodes and since they tend to be a
little bit bigger a little bit grander
well price Seymour Grodd in the second
half of the season but just getting back
to that image there actually is an
episode called the flash of two worlds
that's gonna be the episode the first
episode that we hear zooms speak in so
we might just get a teaser for him in
the first episode like oh my you know oh
my god what's going on here there's this
big threat and then we actually find out
what's going on with them in that flash
of two worlds episode but just remember
Tony Todd is only doing the voice it's
gonna be a Darth Vader thing where where
there's an actor inside the suit and a
different actor doing the voice I think
that that just gives them more time to
cast another actor to be in the suit I
know a lot of people want Rick cuz net
to be zoom he was cast on another show
he's like he's a series regular on a
whole nother show so I don't know that
they would bring him back they might end
up going the edward clariss route now he
was the reverse-flash from the Jay
Garrick Golden Age comics
that's just more speculation but if Jay
Garrick is gonna be a big character it
makes sense that they would do more
characters that are tied to his era from
the comics the problem is is that a lot
of Jay Garrick characters are also Barry
Allen characters that have just been
updated so we'll see it's gonna be a lot
of fun and there should be a proper
really like a really long trailer coming
in the next couple weeks I kind of
thought it was gonna come today but I
guess they're just waiting they're just
waiting for more footage or waiting for
the DVD release let me know that what do
you guys think about this clip and who
do you want to see come from earth-2
like which big villains or rogues that
we haven't seen yet do you want to see
just speaking about rogues they've
already confirmed mere master and dr.
alchemy the female doctor light is also
coming on too so I'm kind of hoping that
she shows up in the same episode that
mirror master shows up in just because
she has light based powers and she'd
look really awesome going up against
someone with mirror masters powers so
we'll see but while we wait for that
next big trailer everybody leave me
requests for bonus videos and be sure to
subscribe to get everything you just
have to wait a little bit longer and
good luck to everyone that's back in
school hopefully you won't have exams by
the time the flash and arrow start just
in case you guys haven't seen it there
been a couple of their teasers that I
posted for the flash with new footage
you can click here to watch all those
and you can click here for my latest
vixen video they posted a new episode of
vixen this morning thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow